وضع بريطانيا المثقل بالاضطرابات على وشك
ان يصبح اكثر ارباكا يخاطر رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني الذي لم يمضي على توليه قياده
الحكومه ثلاثه اشهر بفوضه جديده في البلاد
بدايه العام المقبل مع رفضه مطالبه نقابات
برفع الاجور
فالاضرابات تتضاعف عددا ورقعه انتشارها
تتسع لتشمل قطاعات عده بعضها يشهدوا
اضرابا لاول مره كادرابات قطاعين الممرضين
والاسعاف في ديسمبر اضافه الى تهديد
نقاباتها بالمزيد من الاضرابات في يناير
ما ينظر بمرحله مقلقه قد يواجهها
البريطانيون في عام 2003 2020
لمده يومين اذا تعرضت جدتك لازمه قلبك
تشير استطلاعات الراي الى تراجع الشعبيه
حزب المحافظين الذي يحمله عمال القطاع
العام مسؤوليه الحياه الناس الاخير
ومعرفه عن تحقيق مطالب النقابات لاسباب
يقول انها اقتصاديه يتجه سوناك الى فرد
قوانين تضبط حركه الاضرابات قوانينه تثير
الجدل في بلد يعطي قيمه كبيره لحريه
الاحتجاج
هؤلاء العمال
واذا كان ذلك يعني اضراب العمال فليكن
ولكن اذا جعلت ذلك مخالفه للقانون فانا لا
اعتقد ان هذا امر عادل
ومع اتجاه السوناتا لطرح قوانين للحد من
تحركات العمال هذا لا يبدو ان النقابات
التي تملك زخم الاضرابات تنوي التراجع عن
خطوطتها قبل تحقيق مطالبها من لندن عروب
عبد الحق العربيه